alright i just finished work which means
it is time to sit down and watch the
gotham knights gameplay demo i am
watching this on the dc channel
um feels like it's been a minute since
we saw anything from this game i believe
it's coming out in september and i think
i know a fair bit about it but i'm still
down to see more um excited to see this
this has been framed kind of as a
walkthrough so
i'm hoping we get a mission from stop to
to
to start to stop because i very much
want to see how much depth there is in
this it's very challenging to make
something that has a compelling
narrative but also allows drop-in
dropout co-op some other games have done
it pretty well recently some other games
have done it very poorly recently so
i don't know i have some questions
let's see how it goes very excited to
watch
content inappropriate for children
oh no
[Applause]
hi i'm jeff elenor game director at
warner brothers games montreal and today
i'm really excited to share with you
gameplay footage featuring nightwing and
red hood from our upcoming game gotham
knights
cool let's go they usually talk for a
little longer than that that's very
efficient
hey it looks like gotham
i feel like oh
they nailed the gothaminess of it
it's an aesthetic i really like
it's a grimy neon city
dark nighttime
we're joining nightwing also known as
dick grayson midway through the game
story as he patrols our city
all of the knights can unlock heroic
ways of getting around the city for
nightwing it's his glider the flying
trapeze
the regulators gang are engaging in
hacking crime so it's time to bring some
vigilante justice to the bad people
an interesting alternative too each
crime in gotham nights plays like a mini
game mode with rules and optional
objectives
to knight wings fighting style acrobatic
ping-pongs around the battlefield
while you can play the whole game solo
you can also protect gotham and co-op
with a friend
here's red hood red hood gained new
abilities after being resurrected by an
assassin wow okay here he's just a
mystical leap to move across the rooftop
springboarded by his own soul two guns
successful attacks
and timing my strikes and combos
correctly makes it build faster
once the bar is full heroes can unleash
powerful abilities
all right
red hood's range attacks are a little
louder he fires non-lethal rounds that
still do a lot of damage
it's a very nearly focused game i wonder
what it looks like when redwood hits
somebody
here's red hood's barrage ability which
deals piercing damage to interrupt
armored attacks
the ui you're seeing can be customized
to your preferences what's on screen is
what i like but you can set it the way
you like
i'll pause this for one second
they presented themselves with uh
an interesting problem here
nightwing looks fun that one looks very
similar to arkham batman i don't doubt
i'll make tons of arkham comparisons
throughout this video it's very
difficult not to even though they are
not part of the same universe um
nightwing looks fun i felt like maybe a
couple of the animations were a little
bit stiff but
he's flippy he's acrobatic as he should
be i feel like he looks fun to play
i have absolutely no desire to play red
hood and i feel like a lot of players
are going to feel that way based on this
gameplay it looks like standing and
shooting some weak
guns
um
so much so that in my head i was like oh
that's cool it's an npc party member but
i'm supposed to be looking at it as
though it's me or a co-op buddy
of course i'm
not
gonna be we're not gonna be uniform and
thinking that way not like everyone's
gonna agree with me but i imagine
a lot of players will feel the same way
because this is advertised as like a
a melee based game that's a very core of
the gameplay that's been a core of the
same only games we've had recently and
people are gonna have trouble separating
those two also his baton's just right
through his head right now um
red hood looks really really really
boring to play and that's fine if nobody
has to play him
right
i think that it's only two player call
but you can pick from four characters
just showing the difference between
those two
i think was supposed to show variety but
instead it made me think oh boy i want
to play one of these and very much do
not want to play the other one and i
wonder how they balance out what's
probably going to be the reality which
is everyone wanting to play
nightwing
that was cool
you get like a team up
[Music]
i mean the astral jump [ __ ] he's doing
is pretty sick i would like to give that
a try but that combat
now that we've prevented the regulators
from stealing data let's follow red hood
for a bit
the bat cycle is usable by all heroes in
gotham nights
let's watch red hood chase down a
smuggling van in southside neighborhood
that's sick
[Applause]
[Music]
so yeah if you got close you just hit
them with the guns but doesn't that sort
of defeat the purpose of having guns
and he's really slow
[Music]
red hood can unlock the ability to
attach a bomb to thrown opponents so he
can detonate it with a shot later
that dude definitely just died
he definitely just died
red hood added killing
people come on
there's no way he's dead as books
[Laughter]
that's cute npc's recognizing them
that's very cute it's cool
the true vessel looks fun now we're back
at the belfry the heroes home base this
next sequence is from early in the game
as we're just discovering the court of
owls the frame lane
was difficult to look at but it could
just be uh
youtube
the bat computer runs the map of the
city and lets us pursue challenges and
advance the story
how big the map is so bad
how big is it
nightwing is tracking his next story
mission investigating the old powers
club
i do love me some call to the owls the
workbench is where we go to upgrade our
equipment making sure that we're ready
for each new challenge through the game
players find blueprints and crafting
materials by taking on missions and
fighting crime
each blueprint has different stats
giving the player a wide range of cool
choices for their individual strategy
and style look at that
oh my
gear with mod slots is better because
mod chips power up gameplay properties
okay
that's fun
cool space
at this point in the story our
characters are still processing the loss
of batman
just make myself smaller i reckon
[Music]
you could visit him
i could what
he went to yours when
you could visit his grave
you haven't
i'm not the one staring at that
you know
[Music]
sometimes you're an idiot grayson
i like that exchange
interested to
get more relationship stuff as as much
as i feel like
some dick's trailing lines there were a
bit off
back with the synth let's go baby this
is such a tonally like
jumpy players can unlock fast appreciate
to get around the city in a hurry with
the fastback
belfry got anything court related
the court of owls
a secret society as old as gotham itself
we're on the city behind closed doors
according to the polls
okay very exciting i hope they make them
creepy if this all powerful court really
is out there they might be the ones
getting all those creeps out of black
gate
which means they've been getting away
with murder for centuries
i hear you fingers crossed we'll learn
the city looks really good
like not like uh graphical fidelity
crazy but um
like tonight
so swampy and dark city looks looks cool
is that a mullet stealth is always an
advantage
i'm in miami
they have a few guards for a long lunch
too huh
i'm not complaining nice to get a break
once in a while
so what do you think the poor bastard
did
what poor bastard as far as i know i
just got a longer break poor bastard
i wonder what that means
stealth stuff is always good always
excited about stealth stuff
every hero has unique takedowns and
finishing moves and the amber strikes
are faster than silent takedowns but
make more noise
in peace
augmented reality vision helps the
heroes solve puzzles and investigate
mysteries ar shows a trail of blood
i wonder what else it can see
there's something under the floor
[Music]
the hatch is connected to some kind of
network there's got to be a way to open
it
that makes sense that a lot of games do
like
really make any sense it interrupts
enemy armored attacks and deals
elemental status effects
lot of plants
keep noticing them
and
done that's some quarter deal [ __ ]
let's go they better be amazed in this
game i swear to god
a hidden staircase
that can't be good
[Music]
yes
have one of those
i got something for you
heads up
nightwing does look really fun
for anybody wondering how this fight
looks with red hood
check this out kill the intruders first
then you can think about the rewards
just not feeling it
maybe it'll feel way different
red hood takes on a talon gladiator here
one of the court of owls engineered
superhuman assassins
definitely see this because so far
everything we fought looks pretty much
the same
and the ai isn't very aggressive so it
looks like you know they kind of do the
thing where they wait your turn or wait
their turn rather either like finish
killing someone else so yeah
seeing heavies and stuff in the frame is
gonna make things more interesting
this fight is not over
this design looks cool
fight looks fun
[Music]
i wonder if you like find a fight
hard
you can jump out of the level and jump
back in with a different character and
that would benefit you wherever this
belongs to you must be in bad shape
better hurry
the lighting in here is very nice
that must be whoever they kidnapped
hmm
all right team
oh
pre-order now and get the 233 custom bat
cycle skin thanks for that i think that
didn't say ps4
huh
i thought it was originally coming out
on both maybe
not anymore
um
so
i think gotham looks really cool i have
no doubt that i will be into
the story being that it's caught of the
owls
and
it's gritty and dark and it's nailing
that tone
which i'm very into and very interested
in again i think nightwing looks pretty
cool
um
i think red hood looks very
uninteresting and that makes me curious
about how the different characters gonna
be balanced
still not sure how well
they'll be able to tell the story given
the parameters of the type of game
and i would really like to see more of
like what this game does that's
different um i'm gonna play it like
that's that's done
but in terms of like where it fits on
the release schedules this year um i
would like to see what it's doing oh
it's october 25 my bad i thought it was
september um what it's doing that's
different in terms of like
everything in it so far is it's not that
it's similar to arkham it's just similar
to a lot of games
um the
getting loot to level up your suit
paired with
you know slightly changing the way that
you look um
combat's just got some gadgets like it's
the the the detective work look very
similar to the way that other games do
it even though it does fit really well
in this universe
um what is it doing that that's
different that's my question it's not
that everything has to um that's just
the thing that i'm excited to find out
about see if there's
some really cool creative aspect that we
haven't seen just yet not that it's not
creative either but you know what i mean
just um
there's more that i feel like i could
see to be like oh i get what
differentiates this from other things on
the market
and um
yeah i'm gonna play it though
so like we lean positively overall
um very interesting that it's not losing
ps5 or sorry ps4 or xbox one i think the
only other thing that i want to note
about this one is i feel like i remember
at some point there being like
damage numbers on screen and i really
didn't like that because it made me like
is this like a destiny like um it seems
like they took those off i didn't see
any damage uh output
on the ui there so maybe that's not
there anymore and
i will say like i disliked marvel's
avengers so much um
really really did not like that game
people got very upset with me for it
people would probably be upset with me
for not being like 10 out of 10 on this
even though i think it looks pretty cool
um
and i am getting like a little bit of
those vibes here which just scares me a
little i could be completely off base
it's hard not to compare the two things
but
hopefully hopefully not too much like
that game um i just really didn't didn't
enjoy it outside of it being like one of
the buggiest aaa games ever played much
much buggier than cyberpunk in my
experience and that was the one that
like people told down and i was like did
you play avengers because damn it like
bricked my pc it was crazy
um
so yeah i think it looks neat there's a
lot of stuff i really like about a lot
of stuff i'm very excited about
some extra stuff i would like to see
don't think i'm gonna play red hood and
that's okay because i got four whole
other people to pick from
let me know what you guys think how you
feeling about it i would love to find
out